- [Voiceover] So I have a square here
and let's say that its
height is one meter.
So this is height right over here.
That is one meter.
And let's say its width is also one meter.
So I'm talking about the
dimensions of the entire square,
not just the shaded region.
So this is also, that right
over there is also one meter.
What's the area of the
entire square going to be,
not just the shaded, the entire square?
Well, the total area,
total area is going to be equal to
the height times the width.
So one meter times one meter.
One times one is of course one
and meters times meters
we could write that as a square meter
or meter squared, however
you want to think about it.
Now with that out of the way
now let's focus on the shaded area.
Let's think about what that is.
So the shaded, shaded,
shaded area is equal to what,
and I encourage you to pause the video
and try to figure that out.
Well the one thing that
might jump out of you
is that our entire area, our entire square
is divided into these equally
equal, equal rectangles.
So one way to think about it is well,
what is the area of each
of these equal rectangles?
For example what is the area
of that rectangle right over there?
And to figure it out we can say
well, what fraction is that of the whole?
And to figure that out
we have to figure out
how many of these rectangles
has our whole been divided into?
We could try to count them out
or we could say let's see, I have
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10 columns,
and each columns has
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
So we have 10 columns of seven
or we have 70 of these rectangles,
that our entire whole is
divided into 70 equal sections
that we see these
rectangles right over here.
This character, this
character right over there
that is 1/70 of the entire area.
So 1/70 of one square meter
which is of course just going
to be 1/70 of a square meter.
That's just one of these.
That's just one of these rectangles.
Now if we cared about the shaded area
we can just count how many
of these rectangles there are
and we see that there are
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine columns
of one, two, three.
So there's 27 of these rectangles,
of these equal rectangles
in the shaded area.
The shaded area is going to be,
we have 27 of these
rectangles and each of them,
and then each of them have an area
of 1/70 of a square meter.
1/70 of a square meter
and what does that give us?
Well that gives us the area of the shaded
or the shaded area is going to be 27/70.
27 times 1/70 is going to be 27/70.
27/70 square meters
and we're done.
But what I want to appreciate now
is that there's multiple ways
that we could have tackled this.
Another way we could have tackled it
is to figure out what the dimensions,
what the dimensions
are of the shaded area.
So for example.
For example, what is the height
of just the shaded area?
So just that height right over there
and I encourage you to pause the video
and try to think about what it is
and it's going to be a fraction.
Well, we see if we're going
in the vertical direction
we've divided this one meter.
We've divided it into one,
two, three, four, five.
So let me do it a little bit differently.
We've divided it into one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven equal sections.
That might have been
a little bit confusing
the way I just drew it.
So you can see it when
you look at the actual...
Actually let me do it
in a more vibrant color.
We have...
I'm having trouble picking colors.
All right, here we go.
We have one, that's that right over there.
Two, three, four, five, six,
seven equal sections that we've
divided this one meter in.
And the height of the shaded
area is three of them.
So this height right over here,
this height right over
here is 3/7 of the whole
and the whole is a meter.
So it's 3/7 of a meter.
Now by that same logic what
is the width going to be?
What is the width going to be?
Well we can see that the entire meter
has been divided into one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10 equal sections
so going from here to here
is going to be a tenth.
So this distance right over
here is going to be a tenth.
Let me do that in a
color that's different.
So this distance right over
here is going to be a tenth
and so how many tenths represent
the width of the green area?
Let's see, we get, have 1/10, 2/10,
3/10, 4/10, 5/10,
6/10, 7/10, 8/10, 9/10.
So this width is 9/10 of this whole length
which is a meter so it's 9/10 of a meter.
Now to find the area
we can multiply the width times the height
or the height times the width.
So we could say, so I'll write this again.
The shaded area.
Shaded area instead of doing it this way
we could say I have a
height of 3/7 of a meter.
So 3/7 meters
and then I can multiply
that, times our width
for just the shaded area
which is 9/10 of a meter.
9/10 of a meter.
And now what is this going to get us?
Well, this is going to be equal to
the meters times the
meters is going to get
square meters which is what we want
and then we could multiple the numerators
and multiply the denominators.
Three times nine is going to give us 27
and seven times 10 is going to give us 70.
Exactly what we had before.
27/70 square.
Let me write that a little bit neater.
27.
27/70
of a square meter.
And you could think about
why did this work out
regardless of how we did it?
Notice, three and nine are the numerators.
That was how many rows and columns we had
of these little rectangles.
And then the seven and 10
that's to figure out how many
rectangles we actually had.
So this is saying okay,
the three times nine is how
many rectangles we have?
And then the seven times 10 is
what fraction of the whole
each of those rectangles represent
and that's essentially
what we did up here.
So either way, you're going
to get the right answer
but I really want you to
think about why this was.